let's move on to some social media
questions here we've got quite a few
today sesily from Facebook's got
something for us what do the minimalists
think about the mobs that recently
stormed high-end luxury stores in
California let's take a look at this
video
[Music]
TK
crazy
this is crazy
y this is nuts oh my
[Music]
stars yikes this flares my anxiety yeah
it definitely makes me anxious I think
about my favorite poet his name's
Kenneth
rexroth and he has this great quote and
the quote is I write poetry to seduce
women and to overthrow the capitalist
system in that
order but this is not what he meant by
overthrowing the capitalist system this
is opportunism this isn't overthrowing
capitalism and also I'm not a fan of
giant corporations personally uh
especially ones that thrive through
crony capitalism and bailouts and and
all of these other things I'm also not a
fan of giant corporations who do a great
job to make us feel inadequate however a
wrong thing done to an adversary is
still wrong yeah and to go even if I
dislike the corporation even if I
dislike capitalism or whatever I I think
capitalism is a the best system that we
have but I think it's it's so fatally
flawed this is not the answer to that
yeah I mean self-righteousness is very
powerful because it has a way of making
you feel justified in any way you
respond to perceived
injustices you know if I'm not sure
about the rightness of my position then
there's a certain measure of humility
and and and and um carefulness and how I
approach reacting and responding to the
people around me but man if I feel like
I'm the one I got the truth and I know
what's right and you're evil and you're
wrong just makes it easier for me to
tell myself a narrative that says by any
means necessary whatever I do to you and
however I do it I've got the right
because I've labeled you evil I don't
know the context of this situation but
what I do know is I do have a problem
with anyone putting their hands on other
people's body or belongings um um and
and vandalizing it and and harming it or
destroying it um as a way to make a
point apart from something else that
justifies you and having a right to do
that and so um you know this this kind
of quote unquote activism um I I not
only have an ethical issue with it but
even pragmatically what's the evidence
that this actually works you see all
these different videos people going to
grocery store I'm protesting something
so I'm going to go to the the the dairy
aisle and I'm just going to open up
cartons of milk and I'm just going to
start pouring stuff because I'm
protesting is that the best way to
represent what you're protesting is that
the best way to represent your values
what's the empirical evidence that this
is actually getting you something that
you want in fact do you even know what
you
want yeah what do you I mean it's clear
what to me at least it seems clear what
the people want here they want an
opportunity to steal things that are
worth money so they can either have
those things or resell them often people
will call into our show and they're like
how do I get my husband to get rid of
his stuff or even worse how do I get
someone else I don't live with like how
do I get my mother to declutter her
house you know what I'll do is I'll just
go in there when she's on vacation and
I'll essentially do what these people
were doing so maybe they were just
decluttering the uh the mall there yeah
that's by the way why it's so important
to as the saying goes to know what
you're fighting for not just what you're
fighting against because when you're
driven only by hate without anything
that you love it can put you in this
mindset where all you're doing is
tearing down the life the work the
resources of who you have targeted as an
enemy without ever taking the time to
think about what does a win look like
for my cause and I think about the
people you're talking about with the
milk jugs in particular they go to the
milk aisle and they're protesting uh
animal abuse and I totally understand
that and I sympathize with it we've had
a lot of vegans on this podcast far more
than any of the carnivores we've had on
whether it's it's Rich Ro who I just saw
yesterday or Dr Zack Bush is a
plant-based doctor or Dr Joan Kori Leo
Balta so many people who have been on
our show are plant-based or or vegan but
none of those people would I ever see
them going to the milk aisle and start
to pour it out in fact I would think
differently in fact it harms people like
that who behave ethically and do have a
strong desire to change the way that
their life and the culture and society
around them is shaped around the factory
farming of animals but doing that
showing up at a grocery store and just
pouring milk on the floor likely harms
their calls more than it would ever help
them and it makes people who are
sensible like Rich r or like Leo Balta
it it lumps them in with a group of
people that they want nothing to do with
yeah but if you influence one person to
stop drinking what you don't want them
to drink man that goes a long way but it
doesn't make for a cool video or a cool
Instagram post why because as has always
been throughout the history of human
human civilization the things that save
the world don't necessarily make for
great news there's a difference between
being sexy and doing things that heal
the world and unfortunately for our
culture of
picks or it didn't happen real gone
viral or it just doesn't matter the
things that we need to do to make this
world better and to heal ourselves and
other people of wounds often requires us
to show up and do stuff that looks
boring and doesn't make for a Sizzle
real yeah performative outrage gets so
much more attention yeah than compassion
and contribution I hope you enjoy that
highlight if you like to see another one
check out this video right here if you
like to see that full episode so check
out this video here or if you'd like to
dive deep into the full private podcast
subscribe via the patreon link in the
description your support on patreon is
what allows us to keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free